I'm sorry I'm sorry I know many people
hate it but the jump cut is here to stay
and this is why so I'm personally a bit
happy about doing this video because it
gives me a textual excuse to go back to
jump cuts for a video this video is part
of a follow up to two other videos the
first being an outline of the basic
language of film editing basic cuts
where jump cuts were mentioned and
demonstrated and many people in the
comments suggested a deeper dive into
the specific uses and aesthetic of the
jump cut then as well this is a follow
up to last week's video on the dialect
of vlogging and specifically points made
in that video about how the use of jump
cuts has spread to YouTube as a whole
has become ingrained in the basic visual
language of the medium in that video I
asked people what they think YouTube
will look like in ten years and people
including crown prince of logarithm Hank
green generally agreed that the jump cut
would remain eternal and I agree now I
have made use of the jump cut before and
not just in the way that I will
occasionally let one slide because it's
going to be too much of a hassle to cut
around when I first moved to the current
channel following the shutdown of blip
TV I chose to adopt a fairly
conventional YouTube tone both to feel
it out for myself
as I've always been of a mind to tinker
with how I structure the channel and to
blend in with the locals as it were so I
have some experience with jump cuts as
both an aesthetic and as a workflow and
that's how we're going to break this up
to broad category speaking to why the
jump cut is here to stay the first being
the semantic and aesthetic reasons - the
second being the pragmatics and I'm
going to start this off by outright
praising what I see is the unique
semantic strength of the jump cut and
that is its high degree of semiotic
flexibility I'm actually a big fan of
the teleporting jump cut and for a while
I explicitly used a right-to-left
teleport to indicate parenthetic
statements this was something I'm more
or less lifted directly from say Frank
Hank green and
Peter because it is a very effective
form of visual punctuation with
different areas of the set and the frame
used to indicate different types of
statements it also really helps to break
up long complex ideas into smaller more
manageable bites this can serve to
properly differentiate a joke from a
serious statement by moving either very
far from or very close to the camera or
going back to my own example it can
create an aside by literally moving
aside this all has a direct narrative
value in helping better communicate
meaning which is great when you're
trying to get across a complex idea or
unambiguously indicate that something is
a joke now many of these techniques like
dramatically changing framing for
emphasis can be replicated with
conventional cutting this gag wood brach
Mansley where I keep zooming closer and
closer for comedic effect has the same
root idea which is replicating a sense
of unease and invasion of personal space
that would come along with physically
moving myself closer to the camera
however there's a specific device that
can only be achieved by using jump cuts
and that is the use of the set as a
stage when a performer opts to set their
camera and leave the framing unchanged
the resulting video takes on more of the
characteristics of theatre where
specific locations within the stage take
on meanings that aren't properly
replicated purely by position within the
frame while a close-up works to create a
psychological sense of closeness that
effect is amplified if it's cast against
a fixed canvas that more directly
communicates the speaker moving
physically closer to the camera and by
proxy the viewer all of the meanings of
depths are made more potent by giving
more meaning to near and far likewise
moving to the left to indicate an aside
is more potent the more meaning left has
if less is a physical characteristic of
the space rather than simply an
implication created by the movement of
the camera to put another way stage left
is more meaningful than frame 'lest
what this translates into is
the jump-cut style allows for a degree
of intimacy that other editing styles
can't quite replicate by virtue of how
it creates a stage rather than just a
frame this ability to set a stage and in
that stage create a replica of the
intimacy of theater is I think a unique
strength of the style I wanted to
emphasize this first because I do think
it's important to defend the aesthetic
value of the jump-cut rather than just
saying well it solves a bunch of
pragmatic problems speaking of that
jump-cut solves so many pragmatic
problems it's not even funny for the
current iteration of the channel I use
close-ups to cover edits and to create
emphasis
I am almost always on screen because
lip-reading is a fundamental pedagogical
tool many people can absorb information
better or faster when they are watching
a face say it rather than just hearing
it and it minimizes my conflicts with
copyright robots by minimizing how much
copyright content I need to use on
screen
however this in turn means that
everything needs to be recorded on
camera and because I have a personal
desire to make my image quality as good
as I can as a small way of standing out
from the crowd I don't want to make
close-ups by just zooming in like look
at this look at the drop in clarity
that's better this all means that every
video is recorded twice at minimum all
the way through in order to get all the
footage that's going to be needed to
weave everything together which straight
up doubles my record time now that's me
that's my process is it worth it maybe
there is however no question that using
jump cuts instead dramatically
simplifies the process and that's for me
in an environment where I have the
control where I can record things
multiple times and I can change the
camera configuration the jump cut simply
gets more valuable the less control the
creator has or the more chaotic their
environment for people who use real
environments again that's real with a
capital R as opposed to a poised
environment like a studio or set there
simply isn't another practical solution
for the vast majority of creators the
number of youtubers running around with
a small crew who could even
Ford to have two cameras running as they
run around to make their stuff is at
most a few dozen and even then it
wouldn't necessarily serve their
aesthetic needs at the end of the day
single camera confessional style is
cheap and fast and that's not a bad
thing because it still takes skill and
thought to do cheap and fast well it's
easier to use the space as a stage or to
use your environment of the canvas than
it is to fuss around with multiple
camera setups and all of the extra gear
and hassle that goes along with it but
it still takes forethought and
creativity to use those mechanisms well
to find a good canvas to know how and
when to use your stage to punctuate your
point but that skill and forethought is
all something that you can learn as
someone running around on their own with
a camera
you don't need eight other people on
your team to figure out how to do it and
how to do it well so with all that I
think that no matter how many people
post in the comments about the YouTube
style and the jump cut and how much they
hate it the jump cut is here to stay
[Music]